während ihr alle daran schwer trag dass
deutschland nach der wahl nach links weg
driftet und es keinen sinn macht in
diesem lande zu leben mache ich mir nach
wie vor sorgen um unsere celebrities es
ist so dass ich heute wieder gelesen
habe boris becker hat ärger wegen eines
mallorca trips er hat mit seiner familie
eine ausstellungseröffnung in mallorca
besucht da hat sohn noah eine dinge
ausgestellt die man sicherlich sehen
muss aber nichtsdestotrotz mobile hat es
wieder mit dem gericht zu tun bekommen
und er ist wieder im verschiss und er
ist ja nicht der einzige wenn es nicht
becker ist dann ist es beckenbauer und
wenn es der nicht ist dann ist es ein
anderer ich sage wir haben eine gewisse
anzahl von legenden unser franz
beispielsweise da sehe ich ihn der in
irgendeiner form den den den sommertraum
nach deutschland geholt hat es ging
nicht mit rechten dingen zu wo geht es
denn mit rechten dingen zu frage ich
mich in der politik doch bei euch doch
auch nicht aber letzten endes ich bin
dagegen dass die neu in einer form in
einer speziellen welt leben wo ihnen
alles durchgelassen wird was sie tun
aber grundsätzlich die legenden die
partie wir haben und pommes gehört
zweifelsohne dazu ich wäre nie vergessen
ich saß in irgendeinem flieger von köln
nach münchen kurzstrecke um da der pilot
zurück gesagt boris becker hat wimbledon
gewonnen hat der ganze flieger
applaudiert und heute erinnere ich mich
noch an diesen moment und da steht er
der arme kerl und hat wieder ärger und
wird wieder von irgendwelchen reportern
deswegen belästigt weil er
offensichtlich
seinen seinen sohn in mallorca besucht
das was ich hätte tun dürfen und jetzt
ist er pleite der arme kerl es ist
irgendwie es ist dieses gefühl muss es
denn sein dass wir uns an diesen
personen so abarbeiten die frage stelle
ich mir auch und das ist natürlich in
meiner position für uns bei bild eine
extrem schwierige frage ich bin jahrgang
80 tatsächlich genau der jahrgang der
wegen boris becker eine extrem
erfolglose tennis karriere begonnen hat
und boris becker ist für mich einer der
größten helden meiner kindheit und ich
kann hier offen bekennen am liebsten
würde ich nur schöne geschichten über
das schöne leben des boris becker bei
bild berichten aber er steht eben
manchmal vor gericht und mir blutet
dabei das herz kann ich sagen wenn ich
boris vor gericht sehe wenn ich all
diese geschichten dort ausgebreitet sehe
aber auf der anderen seite ist er eben
neben dir neben franz beckenbauer einer
der menschen die fast jeder in
deutschland kennt und wenn er vor
gericht steht ist es das was wir
nachrichtenlage nennen ich bin da auch
tatsächlich zerrissen ich weiß nicht wie
geht man mit jemandem der uns solche
großartigen momente beschert hat der
deutschland so unendlich stolz gemacht
hat der an ein wunder für dieses land
war und der in seinem leben danach
offenbar wie wir alle vermutlich schon
entscheidungen getroffen hat die nicht
so doll wand und die daneben vor gericht
geführt haben wenn du genau das was du
jetzt gesagt hast auch schreiben würdest
ich bin ein fan von boris becker ich
schreibe das was ich schreibe jetzt mit
blutendem herzen was macht der trottel
wieder er steht schon wieder vor gericht
warum tut er mir warum du denn dieser
nation das an das würde ich finde ich
richtig finden und das wird auch die
nation verstehen hier ist jemand der
sich dauernd um kopf und kragen redet
ich weiß wovon ich rede
aber ist es wirklich reicht das auswirkt
das dann nicht auch wieder wird das da
nicht bigott zu sagen es mir blutet das
herz aber jetzt schreibe ich jetzt habe
ich trotzdem warum tut er da sagten
fakten fakten wenn er vor gericht steht
und wenn er wenn es wenn es erwiesen die
zahlen sind da seine ganzen
insolvenzen ihrer hingelegt hat das ist
auch eine große leistung und da ist auch
viel blödsinn dahinter oder sind
unruhigen dort hatte wissen wir alle
also ich mich verstanden vielleicht noch
niemandem
konstruktiven praktischen vorschlag
machen vielleicht müsste es eine bürger
und unternehmer initiative zur rettung
deutscher idole geben die in ihrem leben
ein paar finanzielle doppel fehler zu
viel gemacht haben und boris becker
gehört dazu nein man müsste vielleicht
weil erste untersteht ja auch dem
rechtsstaat man kann nicht sagen eine
erholung machen was er will ist es ja
nicht gesagt ob man müsste vielleicht
das verstehe ich ja wir deutschland gibt
es so viele wohlhabende unternehmer
wieso hat man noch nie haben sich ein
paar zusammen getan und gesagt hinter
den kulissen okay wir lösen jetzt die
probleme des boris becker wir haben ihn
daraus damit nicht jeder wenn er ihn im
fernsehen sieht denkt sie an diese
finanzprobleme denkt wenn man möchte ihm
boris becker sieht hat er
gesundheitliche probleme man möchte
eigentlich an wimbledon an diese
großartigen erfolge denken ja man müsste
ihn unterstützen die unternehmen die
familienunternehmer an marianne kripo
legte machen und bis kredite den
kulissen den boris becker sanieren
finanziell sanieren sanierung eines
helden seiner sollten unternehmer boris
becker saniert
also tatsächlich er ist natürlich der
boris becker ist der held aller unsere
kindheit ja genauso wie franz
beckenbauer haben wir gehört michael
schumacher also so viele tolle sportler
und helden und ist natürlich tragisch zu
beobachten was dann passiert aber boris
becker hat natürlich auch etwas
geschaffen hat unglaublich viel geld
verdienen hat er sich ein paar nicht so
schön aber
es ist trotzdem eine idee ich meine wir
finanzieren so viele kunst hingenommen
unserem finanzieren darauf neue brücken
und schwimmbäder wird die marode sind
und kunstwerke und musik
die
finanzierung die finanzierung leben
denken
lieber in die idee es wäre halt auch die
finanzielle unterstützung von
straftätern mutmaßlich von
steuerhinterziehung mutmaßlich von
leute bescheid die ihr geld nicht zurück
wegen mutmaßlicher
also das wären denkmal schon mit
kratzern aber vielleicht überwiegt das
andere ich glaube übrigens bei dem
aktuellen fall
ist die wahrnehmung der
berichterstattung gar nicht so sehr
deutliche bor ist sondern ich glaube
dass da auch mit williams lasst ihn doch
mal in frieden es geht nämlich darum
dass er meine reha zentren aber dass er
die reise von mallorca nach ibiza oder
umgekehrt dass er das beim gericht nicht
vorher bei dieser furchtbaren richterin
weil ich jetzt parteispende in england
gesellschaft bei dieser richterin nicht
vorher angemeldet hat wie er es hätte
anmelden müssen deshalb ihm sozusagen
dass das gericht deshalb so derart
hetzjagd mit ihrem veranstaltet ende
lässt glaube ich auch in der wahrnehmung
seine spuren denn die leute sagen er ist
doch unser held lasst ihn doch jetzt mal
was ist es denn wenn die komische frau
die ihnen da die jagd und zum thema
straftäter mal muss man natürlich sagen
dass wir in deutschland deutlich andere
straftäter gerne resozialisieren und
boris hat so er denn einer sein sollte
diese chance ja gar nicht bei jeder
vermutliche vermeintliche fehler sofort
natürlich in medien zu denen auch wir
gehören gar keine frage wieder groß
wieder groß thematisiert wird also
deswegen die kombination aus er muss
sich dann vielleicht einmal ehrlich
machen mit seinen vermögensverhältnissen
und dem was rose vorgeschlagen hat
selbst einmal schutz der der schutz
lebende denkmäler genau wie wir die
frauenkirche in dresden wieder aufgebaut
haben wollen wir mit steuergeldern oder
mit
privatwagen der
steuergerechtigkeit
wir können das auch noch in einen
theologischen zusammenhang hineinbringen
denn wir sind ja eigentlich eine
christliche kultur und da wissen wir wer
ohne sünde ist der werfe den ersten
stein auch
boris becker hat nicht das richtig
gemacht aber wir sind da auch nicht
perfekt außer man soll sich nicht über
andere erheben man macht einen
schlussstrich und finanziert lebende
denkmäler das finde ich ist das
stichwort workshops wird ja immer gerne
in diesen tagen kritik gewinnt da wurde
wieder die chance verpasst auch mal
wirklich überall
wir haben heute müssen wir so für eine
der großartigsten figuren in unserem
land gefunden und beim apropos talkshows
an meine emotionen gehen hoch wer so
noah der der auslöser dieses elends war
bei mir bei late night hat boris becker
den so den namen von seines sohnes noah
verraten es muss also 27 jahre her sein
die ganze nation hat gerät wie heißt das
kind von boris becker ich sage das heute
basiert hat er hatte auch gemacht er hat
nur dank schlagseite ich hoffe doch
so schließt sich der kreis
[Musik]